you were watching ColdFusion TV hi
welcome to another ColdFusion video
looking through all of history you would
think that the mobile phone has caused
the most rapid changes in daily life
ever seen phones have altered our
expectations of what's possible and even
our mental process now we expect to have
all things with us at all times in our
pocket the entire world is at our
fingertips instantly we even tend to
perceive time in such a way where a few
seconds is an eternity if a phone takes
more than a few seconds to boot up and
snap the perfect shot that's just not
good enough we are able to read watch
listened to consume and sometimes even
create from anywhere at anytime what
I've just described is the smartphone
revolution and it's only a decade old
before the smartphone in the 2000s and
90s
phones were a lot less than this they
just made phone calls had a basic
organizer and in last years a modest
camera and very basic Internet if you
were lucky but go back into the 1980s
and mobile phones just did one thing
make phone calls but the question is
what was the first one of these
primitive phones that just made phone
calls what was the original phone that
would become the grandfather to all the
billions of phones in our pockets where
did it come from who invented it and
what's the story behind it in this video
we'll take a look this video is brought
to you by Squarespace one of the easiest
ways to make a website I'm building a
ColdFusion website now and if you have a
suggestion for what you would like to
see on the website let me know below if
you want to make your own website go to
Squarespace comm slash ColdFusion to get
10% off your first purchase
to start the story of the first mobile
phone we have to go back to the 1960s
technically at this time
mobile phones did exist but only in cars
and if you had one you were the boss of
the town a real high flyer as it turns
out since the 1940s
car phones had enjoyed limited use in
large cities of the United States
putting a phone in a vehicle was the
only way to make the mobile this is
because the phones took so much power to
run that only car batteries could supply
it another drawback was that for a given
area only 12 channels existed so most of
the time you'd have to wait to use a
network just to connect to a call could
take 30 minutes that's just the way it
was and the way it always will be until
1968 that is in this year the Federal
Communications Commission asked 18t to
fix this issue
AT&T then came up with a cellular
architecture its aim was to break up the
large areas of coverage into smaller
ones so that multiple people could use
their phones in their cars at the same
time regular mobile systems use a
central high power transmitter to serve
an entire city but this way only one
telephone call can be handled on a radio
voice path at one time amps makes many
more radio channels available at one
time to many more customers by using a
number of low power transmitters each
transmitter is the heart of its own
separate area or cell as a vehicle
drives from one cell to another advanced
electronic equipment at a central
location called a mobile telephone
switching office automatically transfers
the call by telephone line to another
cell without the caller knowing it I
didn't have my phone would be disaster I
don't know what I do really have you
back to coming off the tall ways looking
for a phone customers yelling screaming
where are you why haven't you called why
don't you care around the same time
Motorola had a car phone division and
didn't want AT&T to have a monopoly on
products that could take advantage of
this new system motorola fear that this
would be the end of their mobile
business if they didn't do anything so
they decided to develop a phone to
utilize this new cell technology and
asked a man by the name of Martin Cooper
to speed
have the project in 1972 he got started
the thing was there was a lot of riskier
because at the time Motorola didn't
really have the capital to absorb any
failures if they spent a whole bunch of
money on this project and it failed it
could spell the end for Motorola AT&T on
the other hand were giants they could
throw as much money as they wanted
without worrying it was David versus
Goliath
one day while thinking about this
problem Martin Cooper recalled a comic
strip called Dick Tracy it usually
involved the main character talking into
a mobile wristwatch he is an ad from the
1960s depicting a toy version of the
watch Tracy the kids commend kids it's
here at last the new Dick Tracy two-way
wrist radio that keeps you in constant
touch with your buddies broadcast from
room to room and even house to house no
wires needed yet voices traveled back
and forth radio on the open road from
one bike to another or when out hiking
this gave Martin an idea and he began to
think about the problem differently why
assign a number to a desk a home a
building a car or even a place at all
why not assign it to a person you can be
connected wherever you are to whoever
you wanted this was a revolutionary idea
with this thought
cupid defied the industry's narrow
vision of car phones and went for the
idea of a personal portable form of
communication now that he had the vision
all he had to do was set his team up to
build it but could this even be done
nobody knew Martin was banking on a
brand new technology that could make
this vision a reality the microprocessor
it was a tiny chip that could do the
same thing as many Khafre and components
with much less space and much less power
consumption surprisingly by March of 73
Cooper and his team had a working
prototype on April 3rd in 1973 Martin
introduced the DynaTAC phone at a press
conference in New York City to make sure
that his phone actually worked before
the press conference he decided to place
the very first public cell phone call
he decided to call an engineer called
Joel Engel he was the head of a tea and
teas rival project someone simply called
Joel just to tell them that he'd beaten
them to the mobile phone in that first
call we didn't know it was gonna be
historic in any way at all
we were only worried about one thing is
the phone go to work when we turn it on
fortunately it did in 1983 after years
of development Motorola introduced the
first portable cell phone to consumers
it was the DynaTAC 8000x it almost
weighed one kilogram and was absolutely
huge because it needed so much battery
to power it despite all of that battery
a full charge took roughly ten hours and
it offered only 30 minutes of talk time
and to top it all off its price was
almost ten thousand dollars adjusted for
inflation so when you hear all of that
you're probably thinking that this
mobile phone product was a failure
well actually far from it as it turns
out the value of talking anywhere at any
time made the cost worth it and the
phone eventually became a success
kicking off the mobile phone revolution
when Martin made the first mobile phone
call back in 1973 there was only one
real cell phone now there are more
mobile phones than people
so what smarten up to today at age 88 he
sits on committees supporting the
Federal Communications Commission and
the United States Department of Commerce
so that's the story of who invented the
very first mobile phone I say good on
Martin for taking the risk and thinking
outside the box
he literally changed the world and all
of our lives anyway that was just a
quick little piece of history thanks for
watching
feel free to subscribe if you just
doubled across this channel this has
been - go go you're been watching cold
fusion and I'll catch you again soon for
the next video cheers guys have a good
one
[Music]
cold fusion entry thinking
[Applause]
[Music]